salut les terriens s'allumer carrière je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver
notre invité principal ce soir c'est
bernadette chirac
alors d'arrêt et irak bonsoir si vous
appelez bernadette ou bien vous préférez
madame chirac ou bernie bernet
bernadette
[Musique]
donc bernadette
bernadette est ici ce soir pour parler
sexe drogue et rock'n'roll
abassis ardisson vers l'après vie même
si vous n'êtes pas chez drucker a quand
même
en p1 nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de vos origines
familiales de votre vie de votre mari de
votre action humanitaire et de vos
sorties nocturnes
vous êtes un de faire les yeux noirs que
vous faites à votre mari conduit par une
autre femme bernadette c'est pas les
yeux noirs
[Musique]
oh
bernadette re bonsoir vous avez déclaré
me contenter d'être les pousses du
premier retraités de france non merci
tant que je peux être utile je continue
il y a tant à faire pour les enfants
hospitalisés
les adolescents les handicapés les
personnes âgées et bien cette année
encore vous continuez l'ex première dame
de france est toujours madame pièces
jaunes l'opération a commencé le 5
janvier elle se poursuit jusqu'au 12
février aux côtés de lorie et d'un
nouveau parrain christian karembeu c'est
un garçon absolument charmant qui est
très très gentil avec les enfants qui
sait leur parler qui est joyeux qui
communique bien aussi avec les équipes
soignantes avec les parents et il a
accepté tout de suite d'emblée de donner
du temps pour les petits enfants malades
hospitalisés
comment on fait pour donner donc les
fameuses tirelire alors il ya les
tirelires que nous avons relooké l'année
dernière
avec un personnage pile est un
personnage face n'est plus la petite
maison on les retire ces tirelires dans
les dix sept mille bureaux de poste de
france qui est notre premier partenaire
et quand l'opération se termine le 12
février on les ramène plein si possible
au bureau de poste et puis à internet
c'est price minister et les clients
quand ils vous achète sur priceminister
ils mettent dans leur panier comme on
dit ce qu'ils achètent et à la fin ils
ajoutent des e-pièces-jaunes c'est la
naissance des e-pièces-jaunes au jour
dernier vous avez récolté 3,5 millions
d'euros c'est pas mal oui enfin nous
sommes en un peu en perte de vitesse oui
mais de toute façon c'est les français
sont très généreux et je trouve que
trois millions et demi d'euros déjà
quand on a beaucoup de difficultés dans
beaucoup de familles du chômage il faut
remercier tous ces instructeurs sont
solidaires de notre de nos pièces jaunes
quoi quand on voit ce que vous faites ça
ne peut qu'inciter à donner en 2010 la
fondation à financer 399 projet à
commencer par plusieurs maisons des
parents pour permettre aux parents
d'être présent aux côtés des enfants
hospitalisés et depuis 1990 il ya eu 6
1700 projets financés dans 433 ville
quarante et une maison des parents
838 chambres mère-enfant verra ça un
troisième partie de l'émission 42
maisons des adolescents et 1059 pompe
antidouleur et last but not least la
cour des comptes a qualifié d'exemplaire
l'utilisation des dons collectés c'est
pas le cas de tout le monde bravo
[Musique]
voilà bravo
alors bernadette votre nom de jeune
fille c'est bernadette chodron de
courcel
vieille lignée française anobli par
napoléon iii
votre oncle geoffroy était aux côtés du
général de gaulle quand il est parti à
londres le 17 juin 1940 c'était sur les
deux camps voilà votre père jean louis
lui dirigé des manufactures les émaux de
briare et les faïences de gien il été
fait prisonnier à la guerre en 40 et il
a passé quatre ans en captivité ensuite
alors famille très catho un métier dans
une école qui s'appelait sainte marie
des fleurs et des fruits c'est joli ça
non c'était pendant la guerre où j'avais
quand même 12 km à faire à bicyclette un
jour j'étais demi-pensionnaires et c'est
papa c'était le nom de cette école elle
s'appelle toujours comme ça alors vous
avez toujours un chapelet sur vous dont
temps qui vous a été donné par jean paul
ii ça me rassure j'essaye de prier le
plus possible dans un jour n'est pas
assez sûrement là vous l'avez le
chapelet non je n'ai pas sur ce lien
vous n'êtes pas inquiète alors
alors votre mère vous avez du quai à la
dure elle avait une phrase terrible
c'est qu'on ne se couchent que pour
mourir j'ai été élevé sévèrement c'est
vrai mais j'en dis merci à mes parents
parce que ça va être beaucoup après
surtout quand on est un époux jacques
chirac il faut être bien dressés
1 sacd animal alors votre père suit vos
études vous pousse vers sciences po où
vous entrez en 1950 et c'est là que vous
rencontrez jacques chirac car la
première fois que vous le voyez vous dit
c'est quoi cette escogriffe qui remuent
nerveusement la jambe il a fait
longtemps d'ailleurs n'at il ne fait
plus de témoins voile est un signe de
l'âge
il avait déjà beaucoup de culot ouais et
alors après ça bon magie fait partie de
son groupe de twilight il y avait quand
même le choix
sa mère se prend d'affection pour vous
et au moment où il tombe amoureux d'une
américaine à la nouvelle orléans je
crois que 151 elle vous supplie de le
ramener à la maison parce qu'elle
voulait pas avoir une belle fille
amérique voilà elle avait très peur de
ça voilà alors chez vous c'est pas
pareil hein jacques chirac est quand
même le petit fils d'un instituteur
franc maçon il est pas religieux il n'a
pas fait sa confirmation et il n'a pas
d'argent il été baptisé comme oui mais
bon si ses parents m'avaient demandé ce
qu'il fait sur moi un être baptisé qu'il
veut
mais vous êtes accro quand même vous
passez là-dessus quoi comme vous dites
voilà
c'est magnifique il fait beau garçon
chassa il était très bon il avait
énormément de succès auprès des jeunes
filles et c'était de véritables
batailles rangées
il le savait où ça rien c'est un peu
énervant
alors 53 vous fillon c est en 54 jacques
chirac prépare l'ena et vous vous
renoncez à votre carrière universitaire
et vous prenez même des cours de dactylo
pour taper ces dossiers souika
l'abnégation quand même non non c'était
parce que je voulais qu'ils réussissent
il a réussi l'ena du premier coup il a
réussi le concours d'entrée sans faire
damner préparatoire ce qui est assez
rare qui fait que dans votre famille on
se dit finalement une impasse nahmad iep
après m'avoir dit tu nous ramène un
gamin elle m'a dit mais alors c'est un
génie ah ben voilà ça y est alors
c'était pas tout à fait
alors jeunes mariés vous appeler tout le
temps chez vous il est exaspéré quand
ils vous trouvez pas il voulait
absolument vous soyez là disponibles oui
c'est ça ouais mais oui tu es fils
unique qu'est ce que vous voulez alors
tout a toujours tourné autour de luge et
une fois mariés ils voulaient que ça
continue mais aujourd'hui c'est pareil
c'est pareil aujourd'hui vous appelle
tout le temps non mais c'est vrai ça le
rassure prendre le mans alors à l'époque
où vous avez épousé jacques chirac vous
ne vous doutiez pas du destin qui
l'attendait et votre beau père disait
mon fils sera gouverneur de la banque de
france j'aurais bien aimé oui vous
auriez des plus tranquilles peut-être -
et alors des années plus tard le 7 mai
1995 à 19h30 vous êtes à l'hôtel de
ville de paris jacques chirac vous fait
demandé de le rejoindre
vous prenez le petit escalier napoléon
iii en colimaçon et quand vous arrivez
chirac vous dit ça y est je crois que je
suis élue
et la vous ressentez un changement
pratiquement physique chez lui c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là il ya cette
émotion énorme et m'a semblé comme mon
mari avait changé de posture et vous
vous avez changé à part ce moment là
sûrement moins que lui ouais je dis j'ai
fait le bon choix quand même
enfin j'aurais pu en faire un autre oui
alors c'est en plus tard en 2002 vous
êtes la seule à prévoir que jean marie
le pen sera au deuxième tour oui parce
que ce que je sais faire dans les
campagnes électorales
c'est aller dans les rues dans les
villes salué les commerçants
quelquefois il ya des gens qui vous
invite à monter chez eux ça permet de
faire une sorte de sondage à la fin et
de se dire ben y'a pas de doute il ya
tellement de gens qui disent madame
chirac je voterai pour le pen que vous
finissez par avoir une angoisse et je
disais à mon mari à l'elysée vous savez
le pen monte le pen monte je ne vous dis
pas ce qu il me répondait parce que
c'est assez grossier pour moi
sauf que vous aviez raison quoi oui il a
reconnu que j'avais été la seule à le
dire alors vous qui savez tout est ce
que sarkozy va être élu en 2012 mais en
navette d'abord je le pense et ensuite
je le souhaite
alors aujourd'hui vous avez tourné la
page de votre vie de première dame de
france
quand on vous demande si vous la
regrettée vous avez une réponse
formidable dit simplement its different
c'est différent il ya un côté très chic
oms à 9h explain never complain oui
c'est différent [ __ ] on n'est pas
propriétaire d'une
d'une fonction officielle que les
français nous ont confié
démocratiquement par leur vote on sait
très bien qu'un jour quand mon mari a
maintenant
il a fait deux mandats commandes qui l'a
fait demande a donc de toutes façons ils
avaient décidé de s'arrêter et je pense
qu'il faut se reconstruire si on le peut
une fois qu'on a quitté le ses
responsabilités est-ce que différents
vous c'est que maintenant vous vous
éclatez vous ah non mais c'est vrai on
vous a même vu dans des boîtes de nuit à
saint tropez cet été
parce que le fils aîné de bernard et
hélène arnaud est un excellent dj
j'avais d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
amis c'était très bien ce qui est très
drôle c'est quand votre mari vous
demande s'il peut venir vous dit non non
jacques vous n'êtes pas invités oui bah
oui parce que ça va pas avec sa
mentalité talus verrez pas c'est pas son
truc l'écart du roi alors lui ce qu'il
dit mais c'est pourtant grâce à moi que
vous êtes invités bernadette c'est
toujours grâce à lui si je suis assise
c'est pas grâce aux pièces jaunes non et
il dit toujours ne l'oublié pas vous
avez une chance formidable de m'avoir
habituel ça il va saisir soit par oui ça
plusieurs fois par jour mais quand vous
sortez sel c'est un peu une vengeance
par rapport à l'époque où lui sortait
tout seul non
il n'est jamais beaucoup de sorties
c'est pas du tout un monde hein c'est
pas quelqu'un qui dînait en ville elle a
eu tort d'ailleurs ils se seraient mis
dans la poche un peu l'intelligentzia
comme ça tellement quelqu'un qui allait
qui allait au théâtre la musique n'en
parlons pas il n'aime pas du tout la
musique qui ne s'en cache pas d'ailleurs
mais oui c'est un peu dommage alors vous
allez bientôt fêter vos 55 ans de
mariage avec toi criant c'est terrible
les noces d'uranium enrichi sa non c'est
non j'espère qu'il me ferait un cadeau
c'est non
alors vous lui avez souvent dit le jour
où napoléon a abandonné joséphine il
avait tout perdu ou es ce que vous avez
bien lu et le papillon qui tourne autour
de la lampe la lampe qui donne de la
lumière j'avais assez peur de ça vous
crois qu'il nous regarde là à ça c'est
certain il s'assied en général le plus
près possible de l'écran vous voulez
vous dire un mot là
bonsoir merci de m'avoir permis de venir
face maintenant à notre invité du
thunder
[Musique]
isabelle re bonsoir vous êtes né le 23
juillet 1959 à paris vous êtes
responsable de laboratoire dans un
groupe cosmétique votre mari sa là que
vous avez connu quand il était votre
prof de karaté est aujourd'hui directeur
de service dans une compagnie aérienne
vous avez trois filles clotilde qui fait
une école d'ingénieurs à toulouse cani
qui est en terminale et ariane qui est
en classe de troisième
depuis la 6ème ariane accumule les prix
d'excellence chaque trimestre en plus
elle fait du piano et de la natation
elle a beaucoup d'humour c'est quelqu'un
qui a le sens du du deuxième degré
devions nous
en septembre dernier ariane vient de
faire son entrée en troisième un jour
alors qu'elle rentre de l'école elle
ressent une vive douleur au genou gauche
vous dites c'est la croissance c'est
peut-être le sport en tous les cas rien
de grave les jours suivants ariane
continue à se plaindre
et vous lui dites dans quelle situation
est ce que ça te fait mal et elle vous
dit tout le temps
même pendant la natation ce à partir de
là que l'on prend conscience qu'il ya
une douleur qui persistent et qui n'est
pas naturel ni dû à une activité
sportive à gérer vous allez voir un
pédiatre
qui vous envoie faire une radio et sur
la radio on voit une zone opaque au
niveau du genou
on décide à ce moment là de faire une
échographie en urgence à l'hôpital
trousseau
quand les résultats tombent on se dit
cette tâche opaque au niveau du genou
c'est peut-être une tumeur
suite à des réunions de médicales on
nous informe qu'il y aura une biopsie un
prélèvement au ce voila
voila vous devez passer une nuit à
l'hôpital et vous découvrez à ce moment
là l'absence totale de prise en charge
des parents c'est à dire que pour dormir
bayal fauteuils de repos qui à côté des
délits comme dans tous les hôpitaux en
fait qui est destiné aux malade quand il
a envie de s'asseoir
pour manger mais y'a pas grand chose il
ya des cafétérias disposition du
personnel et des visiteurs manger des
sucreries des choses comme ça et puis
bah pour ce faire sa toilette le
lendemain matin est obligé de repasser
chez soi parce que y'a rien de prévu à
l'hôpital dans ce service là oui
alors dix jours plus tard les résultats
tombent et on vous dit que c'est un
cancer c'est un ostéosarcome c'est à
dire une tumeur osseuse malines passé le
coup de massue ben
déstabiliser on n'a plus de repères et
et on se pose énormément de questions
pourquoi un enfant
c'est pas dans la logique des choses on
pense plutôt les personnes plus âgées
mais pas un enfant l'enfant on ne
souhaite vraiment à personne d'avoir un
enfant malade alors à ce moment là vous
prenez la main de votre mari en serrant
les dents et vous mettez un petit peu à
l'écart pour pas que votre fille vous
vois pleurer mon enfant et écoute moi
également mais bon en tant qu'adulte on
a bien compris le sens des mots des
médecins
alors les deux médecins en oncologie
vous explique le traitement que va
devoir subir votre votre fille ariane
d'abord il ya trois mois de chimio
quatre à cinq jours par semaine
ensuite la chirurgie pour nettoyer
effectivement les les parties malades et
ensuite la pose d'une prothèse et
ensuite une rechignons
ça permet d'être sûr que là
la maladie
puis cette complètement éradiqués par le
traitement alors le problème de la
chimio ben oui ce sont les effets
secondaires un mal être généralisé
des maux de ventre des vomissements et
la perte des cheveux c'est le plus
spectaculaire ca c
une épreuve très difficile
à vivre
l'enfant et nous mêmes on le découvre au
fur et à mesure donc il faut être
toujours très proche avec elle de façon
à la soutenir dans ces moments là
alors voulu acheter une perruque mais
elle n'apporte pas l'acceptent
finalement de de se voir comme ça c'est
à dire que lily cheveux ne tombe pas
d'un coup il tombe
par période et puis ce que nous avons
proposé on lui a proposé des coupes et
au fur et à mesure donc on a coupé de
façon à ce qu'ils aient passé grosse
masse de cheveux qui tombent et au fur
et à mesure on s'habitue aussi le regard
s'habitue son visage et la perruque elle
l'a essayée
pour l'instant c'est pas elle
elle porte un petit foulard oui alors
évidemment il ya tout un tas de
problèmes à régler dans ces cas-là il ya
l'école alors il ya des professeurs qui
viennent a mené par des associations
alors il ya aussi les professeurs du
collège sur la base du volontariat qui
se sont proposés de venir à la maison
donner des cours à ariane et ça a été
mis en place et ça se passe très bien
pendant la période où aller à la maison
lachance cas là c'est que ses amis
passent la voir la maison à l'hôpital
enfin ça c'est plutôt bon pour elles
évidemment mais le pire problème dans
tout ça en fait c'est l'épuisement des
parents parce que vous continuez à
travailler on est très soudés pour
ariane et donc on arrive à aménager
notre temps de travail autour
de sa maladie et parce que les nuits à
l'hôpital c'est terrible parce qu elle
est infirmière qui passe sans arrêt tout
ça va on ne dort pas vraiment en faire
puisque vous dormez trois heures par
nuit et quand même non quelquefois oui
oui des fois moins ça dépend il ya eu
des périodes difficiles alors justement
là
les associations ont mis en place
l'accueil des parents eux l'hôpital
et
et donc ça se traduit par la présence
d'un lit d'appoint qui claquent voilà
par exemple dans la chambre de l'enfant
et ça permet aux parents d'être présents
24 heures sur 24 avec son enfant il ya
un salon salle à manger avec un petit
frigo et puis de quoi faire un repas il
ya une salle de bain
soit là avant d'aller avant de dire
travailler
il avantage d'être présent auprès de son
enfant la journée et même la nuit ça
aide aussi le personnel paramédical et
médical de façon à ce que quand les
enfants ont des angoisses des
inquiétudes ils les expriment d'une
certaine façon est le parent peut re
traduire ces expressions d'inquiétude et
d'angoissé auprès du personnel médical
et paramédical
voilà donc voila quand vous donnez de
l'argent pour les pièces jaunes voilà à
quoi ça sert très précisément
aujourd'hui le concert de potes fille
est stabilisé oui fin février
va être opéré pour nettoyer les zones
osseuse et on va lui mettre une prothèse
dans le genou
et après elle marchera normalement
normalement oui il y aura de la
réducation une rééducation longue à
réaliser plus la chimie ouvrant
traitement
il n'y aura que les sports un petit peu
comme le football ou les sticks bien sûr
préconisé et elle continue à préparer
son brevet oui s'exprimer alors
évidemment il faudrait étendre ce
dispositif à tous les enfants malades
c'est à dire par exemple aux accidentés
de la route qui n'en bénéficient pas
encore d'où l'idée de continuer les
pièces jaunes
vous dit isabelle quelle que soit sa
maladie un enfant ne devrait jamais se
retrouver seul dans une chambre
d'hôpital c'est très important
la présence d'un parent ans c'est déjà
un réconfort l enfant
puisqu'il ya toutes ces angoisses du
soir de la nuit d'être seul et puis mes
mêmes
au delà d'un enfant ça peut être aussi
un parent en fin de vie ça peut être
d'autres personnes soit même un adulte a
besoin d'une présence et puis j'espère
et je pense que ces facteurs de guérison
pouvez être fiers de vous même navette
je suis surtout fier quand il ya un
résultat comme la maman d'ariane viens
de le dire mais il est fier aussi de
tous ceux qui travaillent
au sein de la fondation
en liaison directe avec les chefs de
service là il s'agit du professeur le
verger à trousseau qui joue à dire est
un chef de service remarquable mais ce
que nous faisons là la fondation
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
pour le rapprochement des familles c'est
pour nous un des éléments les plus
importants de notre action
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
l'étendre
indéfiniment parce que vous vous doutez
bien que ce sont des budgets assez lourd
en plus de ça il faut que le chef de
service soit demandeur que l'équipe
médicale que l'équipe soignante soit
demandeuses le bâtiment quelques fans
s'y prête pas c'est c'est très variable
mais en tout cas
notre principal je dirais objectifs que
nous poursuivons la fondation c'est le
rapprochement des familles et la maman
d'ariane vous a expliqué à quel point
c'est nécessaire et c'est utile c'est
utile pour le moral de la d'ariane c'est
utile pour le moral de sa famille est
par définition un enfant qui est moins
angoissé qui est moins inquiet
et plus facile à soigner c'est plus
facile pour l'équipe soignante et il est
plus vite guéri ça ça va sur soi
[Applaudissements]
je vais justement exprimer toute ma
reconnaissance pour le service du
professeur le verger principalement
toutes les équipes médicales
paramédicales toutes les personnes qui
travaillent au sein de l'hôpital
administratif ou même aide soignante ou
être péri culte rice et de toute cette
motivation qu'elles ont pour travailler
ce professionnalisme et puis en même
temps elle donne de l'empathie aux
enfants elles sont vraiment à l'écouté
elles sont disponibles etc je pense des
acteurs principaux est important dans la
guérison des enfants et ceux qui nous
attriste un petit peu toutes les deux
c'est qu'il est question dans la réforme
des hôpitaux
en tout cas de l'assistance publique de
retirer des services de l'hôpital
trousseau qui est l'hôpital de l'est
parisien n'est ce pas vous habitez
montreuil madame je crois et pour le
maire pour les mettre ces services là
qui sont des services de pointe comme ce
gi le professeur le verger à necker le
plus élevé a également beaucoup de
travaux entre cours et on voudrait
transférer alors nous pensons toutes les
deux que ce serait très dommage de
couper des services comme celui du
professeur le verger oncologie
pédiatrique de la chirurgie qui est à
côté ça serait très dommage pour des
raisons peut-être très rationnel mais
qui en tout cas sur le plan humain et
médicales ne sont pas valables de les
couper de les andelys trousseau et de
les mettre d'accord c'est ce que vous
avez déjà été confronté à ce problème
d'avoir un enfant à l'hôpital françois
boyer accidentés de la route oui
et je dois dire que l'oeuvre de madame
chirac elle est immense d'abord par la
mobilisation des fonds privés elle a
actionné un esprit de solidarité un peu
à l'instar de de ce qu'avait fait
coluche les restos du coeur ont rêvé
dans un problème de société on ne
soupçonne pas pour ceux qui n'ont pas à
faire un jour ou l'autre à l'hôpital à
la vie hospitalière à l'encadrement
psychologique comme vous le disiez
madame évidemment des patients combien
cette oeuvre des pièces jaunes a été
utile moi j'ai un souvenir une
inauguration de la défaite à troyes
s'était pas grand chose ç'a permis de
financer une petite pièce pour des jeux
pour enfants des petits enfants malade
malade maladie génétique malades par la
contraction maladie qui nécessaire
nécessitait une thérapie un peu plus
longue le rien que le regard de ses
gosses rien que le s'ouvrir retrouver
des parents ce moment là on se dit une
action publique un engagement personnel
ça a du sens et comme vous le disiez
madame ça la seule fierté c'est de se
dire c'est utile à quelqu'un
j'ai regardé je regarde un peu ce que
tout ce que vous faites au niveau des
pièces jaunes je trouve ça admirable
vraiment aussi way et je ne sais pas à
mon petit niveau si je peux aider avec
quelle que soit la manière mais je
répondrai présent c'est très gentil mais
c'est beau
non
bernadette alors je propose un big up
pour mr la nation
[Musique]
en tous les cas un
prompt rétablissement ariane ou
l'embrasserai de notre part et je
voulais dire un truc
mais dire à jacques chirac il a une
femme superbe
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inler 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu